but we're going to begin with an update
on that terrible mass shooting in
Philadelphia earlier this week it is one
of 25 mass shootings in this country
just since July 1st just think about
that for just one moment that's
according to the gun violence archive
prosecutors in Philadelphia are
describing bizarre behavior from the
suspect seen here in the days leading up
to Monday's attack now they're sharing
this information as part of their effort
to understand an act of violence
impossible to fully comprehend for a
community shaken deeply shaken by loss
and grief our Lilia Luciano is there
with more Lilia when you look at the
pictures of this guy walking down the
street just firing away it's very very
very disturbing
it is Gail incredibly disturbing but
officials are telling us that they don't
believe at this point neither the
victims nor the location
were specifically targeted what they are
saying or what they're hinting at is
that there might have been something in
social media and other ways that the
shooter might have
communicated or conveyed his intention
they are also alerting people to make
sure to keep an eye out for social media
posts
prosecutors say Kim Brady characters
roommates avoided him they thought he
was getting more and more agitated as
the days were passing and their way of
dealing with it was just to avoid it and
not interfere with him the 40 year old
alleged gunman was charged with five
counts of first-degree murder Wednesday
after police say he carried an AR-15
style rifle and a nine millimeter
untraceable ghost gun to a Southwest
Philadelphia neighborhood surveillance
video appears to show the moment he
opened fire at random Monday night
killing five people and injuring several
more including twin two-year-old boys
when their mother's car was hit by
bullets how impactful has this crime
been to this community oh this community
is absolutely rocked it's absolutely
devastating prosecutors say they
recovered a well additional ammo and a
gun at the suspect's home the
Philadelphia Sheriff says they're
looking into disturbing social media
posts but they didn't elaborate
Josephine Walmart Father Joseph was
among the victims I really love him
and the fact that you did this to us
like
for your own agenda for your own reason
it's just really pissing me off
this year more than 750 people in
Philadelphia have been the victim of a
shooting
190 have been killed late Wednesday
Philadelphia mayor Jim Kenney filed a
lawsuit against two major suppliers of
untraceable gun parts we are announcing
the filing of this lawsuit to stop them
from continuing to flood the streets of
our city as yet another shaken Community
looks at each other to try and make
sense of what happened
the next Hearing in this case is set for
July 24th in the meantime authorities
are investigating whether the guns were
purchased legally which they say is
doubtful given some prior gun related
charges the district attorney did stress
the important though or the importance
of gun reform in this state Nate
Lillian thank you